and max will make another start here at
nationals park face the padres out at
petco park couple weeks ago got the no
decision had the roughest inning of his
career had that eight run lead with
which to work gave up the grand slam to
a relief pitcher padres came back to win
the last game of that four-game series
good change-up strike three calls
swinging a miss
two batters two strikeouts for max
scherzer here this afternoon
fastball by him
max scherzer strikes out the side in the
first joe musgrove on the mound today
for the padres five pitch mix for joe
fastball cutter slider curve ball change
look at the record doesn't do the year
that joe has had justice five and seven
on the year but he's posting decisions
and i think in today's game that's
really where you can tell some of the
better pitchers if you've got a lot of
decisions on your end you got a low era
you're doing some work he chases that
strikes out first strikeout for joe
musgrove is trey turner two down and the
nats will have runners on the corners
here with two outs in the first inning
fly ball to right field and profar moves
over
to make the catch out of the jam is
musgrove max is ready now the warm-up's
completed joe moscov the padres pitcher
will lead off swinging a miss
fastball by joe musgrove max scherzer
has five strikeouts through the first
time through the padres order here's
tatis
fly ball left field
par back to the wall
he too will come in a couple steps
back to back at bats where the ball just
didn't travel as far as outfielders
thought it might have one two three
third inning for max scherzer here's
trey turner a strikeout victim against
musgrove the one look out that one hit
turner in the batting helmet he's down
on hands and knees and the nationals
will come out and tend to him as now
trey trying to get back up quickly
trainer paul assard can't get there
before turner's already on his feet and
walking toward first base
there's juan soto gonna shoot one into
the left field corner trey booking it
we'll go first to third bob henley's
gonna stop him soto
in the second standing up and the
nationals threatening here in the bottom
of the third two in scoring position
with one away josh bell the hitter
ground ball right side hosmer will pick
it
and trey's just too quick they're gonna
throw behind juan soto who's just kind
of hanging out a few steps off the bag
but the nationals are on the board they
have scored first here in game three of
this series one nothing so soto at
second with two down here's harrison
josh harrison in the left center field
gap and it's by tommy fam he'll pick it
up on a bounce
harrison in the second base with a two
out rbi doubles soto comes in and it's
two nothing nationals looks like he got
a hanging curve ball there just stayed
through it nice so here is stevenson
trying to pick up harrison from second
swinging a crown ball up the middle base
hit center field harrison tearing home
from shallow center grisham's throw the
slide the tag too late he scores
josh harrison slides across the plate
andrew stevenson rbi single
nationals three padres nothing and trace
pereira with a chance to deliver a
clutch hit
pereira to center field
bob henley's waving that right arm again
here comes stevenson the throw from
grisham not in time
another two out rbi knocked by the
nationals barrero played stevenson and
it's four nothing back hits both on
fastballs by scherzer eric hosmer at the
plate
this one is driven out of the yard to
right field a three-run home run for
eric hosmer well that made a loud noise
for sure a three-run shot off scherzer
and the padres do have an answer takes
it out of the yard it's a one-run game
now that's not fernando tatis on the
right
everyone's trying to dress up like this
guy
swinging a miss
97 from max scherzer gets tattooed
swinging that's the second out it'll
bring up jake croninworth as cronin
reflects this one out to center
stevenson's there
and a couple steps shy of the wall he
makes the grab so scherzer puts up a
zero in the top of the fifth national
still holding that 4-3 lead so they're
loaded nobody out and para coming up
lined and caught by conor worth can he
turn it into two yes
fernando gets the foot in the bag the
double play huge for the padres hara
lines out to cronenworth who turns it
into two
it's an excellent snag by jake cronin
worth so bases loaded two outs four back
scherzer 1-2
and a swing and a miss strikes out
scherzer so the nationals will leave
them loaded as musco picks up his third
k it's 4-3 washington he'll be facing
manny machado tommy pham and eric hosmer
four five and six in the batting order
slider got him good sequence there by
max
two quick outs here at the top of the
sixth and here is eric hosmer
another change up this one rolled over
to escobar
one two three for max scherzer in the
sixth see if the nats can tack on some
offense in the bottom half nationals are
set up here runners on first and second
one away josh beldo has been a thorn
couple of singles
bell hits the fly ball down the left
field line tommy pham on the run and
tommy pham will get there to make the
catch
right in front of the wall nice catch by
famine foul grounds profar
moves from right field to left field for
the padres and coming out of the game is
fam i don't know fam hurt himself on
that play that he made over in foul
ground against the wall so far leading
it off in the seventh
swings at the 1-0 and drives it to deep
right field down the line that ball is
gonna go
home run
a blast for jericho pro far and the
padres have tied it up with one swing of
the bat here to begin the seventh inning
wow home run number two for profile
jericks and profiler started to iron
some things out with his swing as well
tatis
still had first base manny machado
coming up
machado hits one of the air to deep left
field back goes harrison looking up and
that ball is gone man oh man oh manny
matches one to left and the padres with
a two run home run for manny machado
have taken the lead six to four
still hitting a thousand
against daniel hudson i'll see escobar
three pop-ups in a walk
flight out to center
back towards the wall
alcides escobar has cut the deficit in
half here in the eighth inning
solo shot his first as a national and
it's a six to five ball game takes some
really good swings today and then
obviously the best one soto to bats he
represents the goal ahead run with
turner the time run at second and one
out
fly ball left field
back is pro far to the wall it's gone
watch soto has put the nationals on top
in the eighth three games for juan soto
out of the home run derby three home
runs
well i guess that answers the question
whether it pitched to him or not
he lives for that situation a tying run
in scoring position for the padres two
down to the ninth and here's trent
christian
grisham will line it in to left center
field that gets in for a base hit from
third comes matteo and the padres have
tied it seven to seven blown save for
brad hand trent grisham said a
frustrating series it's a base hit and
an rbi this game is tied at seven and
manny machado well he's had a career
full of them 11 career grand slams
in there for strike three locked them up
huge strikeout by brad hands who has
three of them in the night but the rbi
single by trent grisham has tied this
ball game pereira into scoring position
at second base so here is alcides
escobar
driven to center this one backs up
grisham to the track it's off his glove
pereira is just now rounding third
grisham can't get it in time the
nationals have walked off the padres
i'll cities escobar a solo homer in the
eighth to get the nats within one and
the game-winning knock in the bottom of
the ninth to give him the win walk-off
hero